[Musique]
même si le basketball a été inventé en
1891 par un Canadien un prof d'éducation
physique qui vivait au massachu site
l'État de l'Indiana se tarte d'avoir été
le berceau ce sport
direction sa capitale
recrue qui fait sensation depuis
quelques mois
c'est le 23 juin dernier à Brooklyn que
le rêve du jeune Montréal est Bénédicte
Mathurin devient réalité ce jour-là
quatre Canadiens sont repêchés par la
NBA mais Mathurin les avant les autres
aussi sixième rang il brise alors le
record du Québécois choisi le plus tôt
sur place sa mère émue et sa soeur
Jenifer une joueuse de basket et
entraîneuse qui est maintenant son agent
la jeune recrue de 20 ans de Montréal
Nord et choisi par l'épée sur la police
[Musique]
Bénédicte Mathurin jouiss ici depuis six
mois et déjà son numéro le double zéro
est visible partout pourquoi le double
zéro alors
le numéro 0 alors j'ai pris double zéro
je trouvais que c'est la même chose
[Musique]
avant ce match de février cité évident
que la jeune recrue avait déjà le statut
de vedette
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi les fans du Game bridge feel
house apprécient-il autant ce jeune de
Montréal Nord
parce qu'il est déjà très très
bons de pointage pour une recrue déjà
plus de 1000 points
dès qu'il entre sur le terrain il fait
une différence une moyenne de plus de 17
points par partie
bonjour
enchanté très heureux de vous rencontrer
nous avions rendez-vous avec Bénédicte
Mathurin le lendemain après la pratique
de l'équipe c'est à côté de vous
Bénédicte naturel on était à l'Arena
hier le nombre de doubles zéro ça m'a
impressionné est-ce que ça vous monte à
la tête de voir qu'il y a autant de gens
qui vous aiment en si peu de temps
qu'est-ce que ça vous fait sauf que
c'est bien je trouve que c'est bien
depuis que j'ai été drafté dans cette
équipe j'ai su les je suis que le monde
m'aimait bien et je trouve que ça a
juste augmenté avec le fait que je joue
bien puis je pense que ça va juste
commencer à augmenter le fait que je
reste je reste dans cette ville à 21 ans
son calme et ça détermination transpire
dans cette courte rencontre merci
Mathurin pour trois points
n'empêche on serait nerveux à moi
Bénédicte est en nomination à la fois
pour recrues de l'année dans la NBA et
pour le prix du meilleur 6e joueur vous
êtes en nomination beaucoup de gens
disent que vous allez gagner la recrue
de l'année est-ce que ça vous met un
stress de plus est-ce que ça est-ce que
vous y pensez ou vous jouez puis il faut
que vous pas que vous ayez ça en tête
[Musique]
il faut que j'aille ça il faut que
j'accepte que je puisse devenir la nuit
depuis 15 ans il en a vu passer des
jeunes joueurs talentueux mais Mathurin
dit-il à ce petit quelque chose de plus
de basket
in the swag mais ils ont quand même de
NBA
Games
est-ce que vous avez amené un peu
Indianapolis un peu de Montréal Nord bon
il y a la famille qui est importante
votre sœur est ici avec vous mais c'est
important de ne pas oublier les racines
pour vous bien sûr bien sûr le monde
sait que je suis un gros un grand fan de
la nourriture haïtienne et j'ai trouvé
un restaurant haïtien qui a ici alors
après chaque match j'essaie d'avoir ça
ici
c'est ce qui m'aide à me rappeler tout
ce que je viens aussi et puis aussi
avoir la nourriture qui m'emmerde qui
puisse cuisiner pour moi c'est quelque
chose de bien Bénédicte à quel moment
vous vous êtes dit j'ai un talent là
parce que sa quatrième cinquième année
du primaire à quel moment vous êtes dit
oh il y a quelque chose qui se passe
trop trop
[Musique]
je trouvais que c'était vraiment
talentueux dans l'espoir
que ce soit l'athlétisme flag football
aussi en quelque sorte je trouvais que
c'était vraiment talentueux et c'est
vraiment voilà
ce que ça allait être mon sport et j'ai
commencé à me les marquer là les équipes
le niveau des équipes à Montréal où
j'avais joué jeune c'est haut c'est ça
se compare à ce qui se sont aux
États-Unis oui mais c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment différent
Amérique
les joueurs c'est là que c'est c'est là
que la mésothée joueur lambier sont
alors les voir grandir et retourner dans
les programmes qui s'étaient auparavant
ça influence les jeunes en s'entraîner
encore plus fort et c'est avoir moi
Lucrèce bouchée
qui qui sont bien présentement ça peut
motiver les jeunes à s'améliorer et à
croire qu'il y a une chance pour eux
aussi
la progression du basketball au Québec
et au Canada et phénoménal même si
contrairement à Toronto et ses Raptors
Montréal n'est pas la veille d'avoir une
équipe des joueurs d'ici se démarquent
Chris boucher Lugan d'or de Montréal
Nord aussi des vedettes qui à leur tour
aideront des jeunes des quartiers plus
difficiles à vivre le rêve et même vous
est-ce que vous allez garder du temps
pour devenir comme un leader dans la
communauté à Montréal pour encourager
les jeunes joueurs et tout ça c'est
important pour vous de rester en contact
avec les jeunes
qui n'ont pas l'opportunité
tu sais que moi c'était vraiment
difficile pour moi d'avoir la nourriture
des fois j'essaie de quand je peux de
motiver les jeunes à dire que qu'il y a
mieux et que de rester concentrer sur
les choses les plus importantes
mais aussi de
de poursuivre de poursuivre leurs rêves
pour réussir il faut parfois prendre des
décisions qui font peur à 16 ans 4 ans
après le décès tragique de son frère
Dominique dans un accident de la route
le jeune Bénédicte quitte sa famille et
s'exile au Mexique vers une académie de
la NBA ce sera ensuite les États-Unis la
folie du basket universitaire avec les
worldcats de l'Arizona où il brille et
où surtout ils travaillent plus fort que
les autres
Bénédicte vous avez du talent vous avez
dit vous l'avez vu jeune mais il faut
travailler j'imagine comment on est j'ai
dit je vais devenir fou mais il faut que
j'aille la discipline il faut que je
travaille très fort et au Mexique et
après à l'université quelle est la part
du travail puis de votre talent
pour moi je me suis jamais vraiment fier
sur mon talon je pense que c'est une
raison pourquoi je me suis rendu
vraiment loin je suis sûr que j'étais
mais ça veut aussi qu'il y avait du
monde qui était plus tendu que moi alors
ça m'a donné l'opportunité de de mettre
mes efforts beaucoup plus des forces sur
sur le travail et j'aimerais travailler
comme le monde qui me connaissent savent
que je travaille vraiment fort et que ça
remonte vraiment aidé de mon talent mais
aussi d'être dans votre travail
homophobe je le disais recrut de l'année
et peut-être 6e joueur aussi est-ce que
c'est possible vous ayez les deux prix
ça peut être possible ça aurait été
donné dans un billet mais
j'espère pouvoir être le premier
et jusqu'où vous voulez aller c'est quoi
votre rêve le plus grand champion de de
se comparer aux grands noms LeBron James
etc
de devenir comme
une légende à Montréal pour les jeunes
que les gens puissent regarder après
dire que c'est lui c'est lui la Russie
moi aussi je peux le faire
c'est quoi la différence parce que votre
carrière est très bien commencé pour
arriver encore plus haut c'est le
travail c'est quoi c'est quoi le secret
c'est le travail et le travail mais
la chose que le monde
je peux pas je comprends pas mais
que ne porte pas vraiment attention
c'est que on est rendu un niveau que
tout le monde veut être toujours voulu
se rendre quand ils étaient jeunes et
quand ils sont ici ils ont tendance à se
ralentir un peu mais c'est là qu'il faut
faire la différence il travaille encore
plus fort qui a décidé de changer
d'équipe dans le bien c'est un peu de
tout le monde par de ça est-ce que le
basket les joueurs vous avez plus de
pouvoir que dans d'autres sports
football américain par exemple
ça fait beaucoup d'années qu'il est dans
un billet quand tu es aussi bon le monde
te connaît tu as beaucoup plus de
possibilités que les autres ceux qui
veulent de rentrer
ça fait plus longtemps c'est ça
une grande vedette dire je m'en vais
même si un contrat c'est comme si au
basket les joueurs
Xavier vous détenez les grandes stars
tout le pouvoir que vous vouliez quand
même particulier comme la revanche des
joueurs sur les propriétaires je suis
d'accord vous êtes libre je suis
d'accord
Bénédicte Mathurin a signé 4 ans avec
l'épaisseur 6 millions cette année selon
les experts il a tout ce qu'il faut pour
ce hici au rein de super vedettes libres
et très riche sans oublier d'où il vit
un rôle modèle comme vous un leader
comme vous ça fait une grande différence
dans un quartier comme Montréal Nord
vous arrivez là vous êtes une vraie
vedette vous avez dit tout à l'heure
vous voulez continuer à garder ce lien
là pour aider des jeunes dire c'est
possible
vous inspirez beaucoup de jeunes vous
êtes conscient de ça c'est pas un poids
trop lourd à porter là non non
c'est pas une personne qui j'essaie de
devenir
c'est la personne que je suis et c'est
quelque chose que je me suis j'ai fait
communement je me suis dit ok j'ai
réussi dans la vie maintenant c'est le
temps d'essayer de d'avoir deux jeunes
de Montréal qui qui peuvent poursuivre
leurs rêves puis c'est ça une équipe à
Montréal de votre vivant comme joueur
est-ce que vous aimeriez jouer à
Montréal
je trouve que ça devrait commencer par
un peu plus avoir de femmes qui sont
impliquées dans le basket je comprends
que Montréal c'est une ville c'est une
ville de hockey mais je pense que les
temps ont changé mais je pense qu'il y a
beaucoup il y a beaucoup de on a
beaucoup plus de gens qui beaucoup de
joueurs de Montréal qui sont en vie
maintenant je trouve que c'est le moral
devrait être plus habitué dans le basket
sont venus présenter c'était plein le
donc il y a un intérêt quand même pour
ça
alors la famille votre sœur s'occupe de
vous beaucoup de votre carrière à la
déménager ici
et vous dites que je pense souvent à mon
frère décédé d'un accident
il vous accompagne partout
c'est c'est pour vous jusqu'à la fin il
va être votre compagnon jumeau
dans tout ce que je fais il va être
présent et
de me lever chaque matin et de faire en
sorte que je m'améliore ce que je fais
les gens de votre mère les gens de votre
famille de Moriana doivent tellement
être fiers de vous là
c'est beau à voir quand comme modèle
j'ai amené un t-shirt que des jeunes
bougez pas
[Musique]
les jeunes de pour trois points un
organisme qui encourage la pratique du
basket-ball dans des quartiers
défavorisés de Montréal ont remis à mon
caméraman Sébastien grand fan de basket
un chandail qu'ils avaient signé c'est à
ce moment que le visage de Mathurin
s'est-il humide alors les jeunes ont
signé pour vous
[Musique]
aussi vous regardez ça je vous remercie
beaucoup c'est à vous c'est un cadeau
qui a un mot qui vous est adressé